Wow, this is an
excellent wine.
You're going to learn how
to make great buys that
taste like $100.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The first thing you got to
do is invest in a corkscrew.
[POPPING]
I try not to be
pretentious about wine.
But if you want to be, I
can help you do that also.
Never do this.
Tips.
You always look at the color.
How to swirl the glass.
You just go like this.
More descriptors.
Vibrant.
Silky.
There's tannin structure.
That's all part of the game.
But at the same time, I
want you to enjoy wine.
Ah.
I'm going to take
you to Tuscany.
I want to teach you about the
principles of viticulture,
the balance in the
soil and microclimate,
and why great wines are great.
[CLINK]
Because this is my home, we will
immerse ourselves in the Tuscan
winemaking history.
I want to teach you how
to really taste wines.
I'm using the 100-point scale.
I give up to 15 points for
color, 25 points for aroma,
25 points for
structure, and finally,
35 points for the
overall quality.
And I have a special philosophy
about food and wine pairing.
I like to break the rules.
I don't even mind trying white
and red at the same time.
And this is a way
to really increase
your knowledge, understanding,
and also confidence with wine.
It's a journey.
It's an experience.
I'm James Suckling, and
this is my MasterClass.